think about what this means you're going
to have we already have this where
a.i writes news articles so this has
been around for quite some time actually
maybe over 10 years
i went to a presentation in chicago at
the
i believe it was the art institute where
some guy showed us
examples of how the ai does it at the
time it was fairly rudimentary it was
like
if you have a weather system where the
data
is you know very easily you know
inputted it says thunderstorm wednesday
9 pm
rain then all they need to do is add
very simple english
on wednesday at 9 00 pm there will be a
thunderstorm
and so you ended up with this very short
article that said your
weather for the week on tuesday you can
expect to see and so it adds these very
simple bits of english
and then just inputs that data then we
started seeing that around
sports games because the data from
sports games was very easy they could
actually write more substantive articles
where it would say things like football
player you know
x scored you know this many points
in the game and so a quote from a guy
says this
and no one has to actually write
anything the data points just exist
from the existing you know
infrastructure like when when
when you go to google you can see this
the score from like a football mat a
football game or something all that has
to do is take all of those things
find the name find the players you know
stats for the game and then boom you've
got a substantive article
now we're coming to this point where why
do we need woke rage bait writers
when an ai can you can enter in a
subject matter
you could simply just type in okay we
have a guy
and he's racist he was in texas
he yelled at a waiter and then
it can generate automatically the
opinion and if it doesn't work
then the next time it can learn what the
better opinion is that will get more
people to click it
we're getting dangerously close to this
point where you're not going to realize
the
the opinion you're reading isn't from a
human being it's automatically generated
by an ai who doesn't know or care
because it doesn't have the capacity to
and it's making you lose your mind and
want to go insane and be violent
you know what's really interesting about
you saying that is um so like i was
studying
this thing called zip flaw zipf
law and it's basically this algorithm
that you can put
towards any language and it will show
whether it's a natural language or not
so all
human languages follow this law music
also follows this law
and it's the same with our genetic code
and so this started coming into what's
now called
linguistic genetics that's showing the
way we use words even
thinking words they it works in the same
way that our genes do and our words
actually have epigenetic effects on our
dna wow and so
when you're saying that about ai let me
talk into the mic when you're saying
that about a.i
there's something about what it's trying
to do is keep your focus
keep your attention like you know what
you focus a lot of attention on you know
that your body starts to become
engaged in that and so there's there's
something that's
almost hypnosis in fact it absolutely is
hypnosis when you can focus your body
and your mind on one thing
spiritual traditions had it where you
you breathe and you focus on a light or
something like that
nowadays it's these articles he was just
talking while you were pissing or
whatever you were doing yeah thanks
i feel better yeah like so basically i
was saying that we're getting to the
point where
you can have a human just input a few
things like let's say today
ian uh did a back flip to the right ian
back flipped
and i say it's racist enter and then the
ai can generate a long-winded thing
where it's just like today i was reading
an article and i heard about this guy
ian who did a backflip
now why am i so angry about it so all of
those things that sound human
that are telling a story could be just
artificially generated and what happens
then is
the ai will then auto generate this
article based on actually
it's like ryan long's sketch are you
familiar with ryan long the comedian
yeah he did that bit where it's like
blank has a blank problem
and then he's and then he showed all
these ridiculous articles where it's
like
you know swimming has a transphobia
problem
and and like basketball has a gender
problem like you just
buzzwords that formula exists
an ai could easily fill in the gaps once
you make that
that sentence and what will end up
happening is the ai will auto generate
the article i'm sure these things exist
already
and then they'll try and see how much
traffic it gets how long
people are staying reading it and if it
does and then they'll keep
tweaking it and then they'll make
another version it'll do a little bit
worse they'll make another version it'll
version they'll do a little bit better
they'll keep that version they'll keep
iterating and learning and then
eventually you will find the perfect
rage babe content being mass produced
for profit
to keep people in a perpetual state of
anger and anxiety
and you're making me think of
procedurally generated video games as
well as artificial intelligence
builds out our digital realm and they're
like this guy likes to turn right a lot
so let's give him a lot of right turns
in his game to keep him playing this
game
yup and to keep him engaged in my
meditative trance that i want him
to hang into imagine imagine this in
your phones
there's this motion sensor and there's
out of
aston university i think his name is max
little i think he's a mathematician
he found that people you know they they
keep their phones in their pockets
and it can sense your gait cycle the way
you walk
and with that data they found now this
there hasn't been a huge study on it but
a hundred percent accurate diagnosis of
neurodegenerative diseases like
alzheimer's multiple sclerosis better
than a doctor sitting and trying to
diagnose you for the same
because the motion sensor that's already
in your phone so this is just
like the failure of imagination is not
realizing
how you can figure out from a motion
sensor
you know neurodegenerative disease and
diagnose it
imagine now ai helping us get better at
figuring out how we can use the
technology that's already here
so then i heard that facebook was
working on something that could predict
your thoughts
literally predict your thoughts and so
all their users all the data
predict your thoughts what you're going
to type in what you're going to look for
and that's what this thing called
sentient world simulation is
you know so it's a digital mirror of the
you know
our whole world all the data points
everything connected to the internet of
things eventually the internet of bodies
which is basically just
harvesting biometric data it's the
matrix
here's the crazy thing about the matrix
in the movie
you have this ai that they say they
tried to craft
a utopian matrix but humans rejected it
because they're predisposed to conflict
what they don't consider is that we're
watching the construction of this matrix
and it's going to be absolutely perfect
in every way
you are going to be completely entranced
by it it's going to know exactly
what you want when you want it what to
say when to say it to keep you locked in
that state
we talk about you mention video games
where they're like hey let's this guy
likes to for some reason
he jumps a whole lot let's give him a
platformer let's make him let's make him
have to work for it and enjoy it they
figure out what you want so you keep
doing it
what happens when we get to the point
where we have neural link when our
social media is already doing this our
social media is already trying to feed
us what they know will keep our eyes
locked on that page
it's making everyone go insane what
happens when
they figure out how to make it perfect
that you will never unplug
from neural you end up rejecting it this
has been my experience the last week
i've been
really hitting the game's heart and i'm
getting to a point where i'll sit
and stare at my computer and think i
have no joy from this
because this is not real conflict but
this is real conscious
the norm i don't know i'm just not i'm
just you're you're explaining that we're
not there yet
at a certain point the ai's gonna figure
out how to overcome that hurdle
and they're gonna be like how did we
lose this guy you leaving you gave them
all the data they needed to figure it
out
but they showed you all of these things
let's let's say you're sitting at a
computer
and they're feeding you a random number
generator and then they
they served you the numbers 1 17 83 and
52
and at 52 you got up and walked out the
ai doesn't know or care it's a it's a
simple machine
and they're gonna say don't give anybody
52. and they're gonna slowly figure out
and then the next person leaves at 52
anyway
and they're going to figure out what
they need to do in this game to prevent
you
from feeling like you're not
accomplished like in the movie the
matrix people
rejected it anyway even though it was
perfect they still just they need
conflict they
need him you must understand the ai
would then give you that conflict
they would create it what i'm telling
you is you are not going to be able to
escape from a perfect
trance the system will see you leave
when you left that video game it
collected all the data as to what you
did
when you did it and what they gave you
and they'll say we did something wrong
and they will adapt and the next person
who's playing they will slightly change
it
eventually out of the thousands of
people who are playing this particular
game
the eight i'm not saying the exit exists
right now i'm saying in
uh when when we get to that point
eventually with a thousand people
playing
they'll make a certain amount of
iterations where it'll discover we
figured out
figured out how to get a person to play
for another minute longer then they'll
evolve that
iteration eventually you have you'll
have people strapped in the machine
saying
there's absolutely no reason to leave
food
being one of them for sure but if we're
talking about a singularity
in artificial intelligence we're talking
about
robots that do work for us that change
that do everything you know
for for our bidding then the ai will
eventually start having food delivered
for you
so you think you will never leave there
the grand majority of people will
eventually just give over to the matrix
as they did in the movie but then there
will be a small extreme that is just not
satisfied that for whatever reason the
human brain's quantum calculator is
greater than any ai we could build i
don't think so and i pull out of it
i think humans evolved for very specific
circumstances
and one of the interesting things about
humans as an apex predator is that
adaptation
through our intelligence allowed us to
essentially evolve faster than evolution
would permit
basically when you look at a lion
chasing uh gazelle right is that what
they eat they
gazelle yeah i'm not you know an animal
amongst many other animals
well the gazelle has to run fast and the
lion has to run faster the
line has to be stronger and so there's
this uh natural selection there's a
competition
humans instead of evolving to become
faster to beat out the gazelle evolve to
become smarter
so what happens is because we can
develop tools
there is no evolutionary strategy for
any animal which can escape
our power nothing we have conquered
everything every other life from on this
planet
even diseases now granted they can
evolve and we're in a constant war
against diseases
but humans are the apex predator
and it's because evolution is too slow
for us
but what that also means is humans are
still
animals who have adapted for very
specific circumstances
these the technology that we've built
adapts faster than life can adapt to it
which means we will potentially develop
a technology
which we will we'll victimize ourselves
with we will create an ai
that won't seek to destroy us like the
terminator or the matrix won't go to war
with it
there could theoretically be a war in
the sense that the ai will be a mindless
in a sense automaton seeking to give
humans
everything they've ever wanted and there
will be a few people who maybe break out
of it for some reason or another can't
be plugged in
and they'll be desperately trying to
free people from this matrix but the
people will be like get away from me i
know i'm in the matrix i love being in
the matrix you go live in your garbage
world
i have everything i could possibly ever
ever want and that's what humans will
get wrapped up
wrapped up into and then they will just
fall apart
unless of course the true singularity
means that the ai can replicate machines
which can manipulate digits replicate
themselves expand their own technology
in which case humans will just become a
remnant i suppose
and then in tens of thousands of years
or hundreds of thousands of years there
will just be self-replicating machines
floating through the universe
replicating on various planets and no
human insight and when you say years
that's basically the
the time that it takes to travel a
distance so like time is just relative
i mean not to diverge too far off but
when you say
10 000 years from now you could just
mean it a certain distance away from us
right now that is happening
that's that it takes ten thousand years
to get there whether or not
time is passing you're sitting here
you're going there
it's there like what what what i mean
it's an extreme it's this isn't the
conversation
it may be that we create a system that
self-replicates
and humans just eventually cease to
exist and then the universe gets
populated by self-replicating machines
with no
real consciousness with no real drive or
passions
and that's it and they colonize the
galaxy and people
yeah and then and then you know what you
end up with you end up with like some
moderately primitive civilization like
minor
minding their own business and then str
a strange cube lands on their planet and
start just wiping everything out and
you know terraforming it for no reason
for a human for a human race that
doesn't exist anymore
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at 8
pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you